(upbeat marching music)
- Good morning, Class of
2025, transfer students,
Eli Whitney students, and
visiting international students.
Welcome to Yale.
(audience applauding)
I am Marvin Chun, Dean of Yale College.
And joining me on this platform before you
are the officers of the university,
the heads and deans of
the residential colleges,
the deans and staff members
of the Yale College Dean's
office and athletics.
We are so pleased to be
with you today in person.
(audience applauding)
Family members and friends
who are joining us remotely,
we extend our warm welcome to you,
and we thank you for
everything you have done
in guiding these young adults.
Congratulations on this
proud and happy moment.
(audience applauding)
Class of 2025, in the
entire 320 year history
of Yale College, you are the
greatest entering class ever.
(audience applauding)
In number, with 1,815 of you joining
as new students this year.
And for the first time, in
at least half a century,
we are hosting opening
assembly on Cross Campus.
This is a place that you
will come to know well,
because you will be
spending so much time here
in Sterling Memorial Library behind us
and in Bass Library below us.
Surrounding this group are
three of the 14 best residential
colleges in the world.
Behind you on your left,
Grace Hopper College.
(audience cheering)
At your front left Trumbull College.
And flanking the platform,
Berkeley College.
(audience cheering)
Where my wife, Professor Woo-kyoung Ahn,
and I raised our two children
when I served as a head for nine, years.
I literally lived right
there on your right.
And also to your front left,
there is the Woman's Table
designed by alumni, Maya Lin,
celebrating what is now 152
years of co-education at Yale
and 52 years of co-education
in Yale College.
To your far right, a block away,
yes, co-education.
(audience applauding)
To your far right, a short block away,
is a magnificent Schwartzman Center,
a newly expanded hub for student life.
Our campus more grand than ever
is embedded within the city
of New Haven, also more vibrant than ever.
And within what is now
the state of Connecticut,
Yale acknowledges that
indigenous peoples and nations,
including Mohegan, Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequat,
Schaghticoke, Golden Hill Paugussett,
Niantic and the Quinnipiac
and other Algonquin
speaking peoples have
stewarded through generations
these lands and waterways.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship
that exists between these peoples
and nations and this land.
In my role as Dean, I have
the privilege of supporting
President Salovey's mission for Yale to be
the research university
most committed to teaching and learning.
What that means is that
I am here to make sure
that you get the best
liberal arts education
and extracurricular life
that Yale has to offer
in the classroom and outside of it.
A good part of what you
will learn here will come
from the faculty who will teach
you in the classes you take
while much will come from your peers
and colleagues around you.
Taken together, these teachers
of yours will give you
the liberal education
that is Yale's hallmark.
And by the time you graduate,
you will have furnished
your mind in the broadest possible sense,
not by pursuing narrow specialized study,
but instead by searching
for new knowledge,
new perspectives, new ways
of looking at the world
and by adding your own.
If you make good use of this place,
you will discover fields of knowledge
that are completely new to you,
and that you have never heard of,
and you will open yourselves
to them and learn from them.
To help you get as much as he can
out of your four years here,
you will get plenty of
advice along the way.
And here are some of my
own to get you started.
Before you even start
thinking about academics
or world domination,
start with the basics.
Take care of yourselves
and not just your own self,
but the people in your lives.
Start by listening to what
your parents and guardians
have been telling you all along.
Get enough rest and sleep,
eat healthy, exercise,
and spend time with your friends.
In the excitement of the
discovery discovery awaiting you,
it's easy to forget this good advice
so remember it in the
months and years ahead.
And there's more beyond these basics
and it's just as important
if you want to flourish here.
This past summer, the Olympic
games were held in Japan
and one of the biggest international stars
was American gymnast, Simone Biles.
She is arguably the greatest
gymnast of all time.
She has won 32 Olympic and
world championship medals,
including four gold medals
in the 2016 Olympics.
She can perform routines of
unprecedented difficulty,
and basically she can fly.
With her performance at its peak
and expectations higher than ever,
it seemed like a foregone
conclusion that she would
take home every gold medal
in women's gymnastics.
But she started off
poorly and then pulled out
for most of her events
because of the twisties,
a disability that caused
her to lose her awareness
of her balance and body position,
both critical to performing
complex gymnastic routines.
Pushing forward risked serious injury.
And so to front page headlines,
Simone abruptly withdrew
from most of the competition.
Her choice did prevent
her from becoming injured,
but it did more than that.
It also gave her teammates
the chance to compete
and to gain both individual
and team medals themselves.
Simply put, she showed how
taking care of yourself
can also be a way of helping others.
Some people say that
winners should never quit,
that they should always grind forward,
sacrificing everything, even
their health and safety.
According to this philosophy,
withdrawing is a sign of weakness.
I disagree.
I am a neuroscientist
and I do not distinguish
between the mind and the body.
I see performance, brain fitness,
and mental health as interdependent.
I applauded Simone's choice.
So did many professionals
who saw her withdrawal
as a sign of strength.
She had the maturity and
confidence to step back,
to avoid injury to herself
and to avoid putting her
teammates at a disadvantage.
Simone did not succumb
to outside pressures
to gain more medals.
She did not need them to
feel valued and respected.
And whether she knew it or not,
performance research shows
that people achieve their best
when they're not trying too hard,
but instead striking the right balance
of exerting themselves and
relaxing, you need both.
And so I ask that you learned
from Simone's champion mindset.
Every single one of you has
earned your spot to be at Yale,
the Olympics of higher education.
You do not have to count
on any test, assignment,
or grade to prove worth.
What's important now is to
enjoy the process of learning
and being in community with each other.
You will feel stressed at times.
Yale will surely challenge you,
but it's important to pace your efforts.
And sometimes that means stepping back,
taking a deep breath, and accepting help.
And you will find people
everywhere who can provide it.
Faculty members, heads, deans
and directors, advisors,
counselors, coaches,
chaplains, Yale health,
Yale College Community Care clinicians
and wellness specialists,
and your friends and family members.
But also remember this,
most of the time, others cannot remove
the pressures that you feel,
you need to do it for yourself.
Caring for yourself and caring
for others will help you
learn from each other,
and that is a lesson that
will enrich your time here.
Yale brings together the
most interesting students
from all around the
world so that you can all
teach each other new
ways of understanding.
You have all earned a
place in this community
because of the promise you have shown
in what you will contribute to it.
When you get to know your
friends joining you this year,
you will find that you
come from every possible
walk of life, bringing with
you every imaginable talent,
every experience, every worldview.
Learn how to draw on your
different backgrounds,
views, talents, and interests,
and how to see the world
through each other's eyes.
Here's a quick demonstration.
It's one that shows a fundamental
principle of psychology,
of how we all experienced
the world differently.
Your program has an inserted
side, the one with the graphic.
Take a look at it now, look
at the top image of the insert
and you'll see an ambiguous
figure that can be seen
in at least two different ways.
Name out loud what you see.
(audience chattering)
Thank you.
So some of you saw a duck,
some of you saw a rabbit.
And of course, if you step back,
you can try to see it another way,
the other way that you
didn't see it at first.
Can you see it both ways?
Okay, good.
If you can't see it both ways,
we can talk to your Dean.
(audience laughing)
So the way this works to help you along,
the duck's bill, you know,
pointing up to the top left
forms the rabbit ears and the
rabbit's nose facing right,
is the back of the duck's head.
Now look at the cartoon
on the bottom of the page.
There are two armies facing each other.
Each army is brandishing
a flag that has the same
ambiguous duck figure,
duck/rabbit figure on it.
And you'll see, on the
bottom eight general stands
in front of the army and
he is urging his troops
with the following caption
that I will read out.
The caption for this cartoon is,
and this is again the general
speaking on the bottom,
trying to rally his troops,
he's saying, "There can
be no peace until they
"renounce their rabbit god
and accept our duck god."
It's a New Yorker cartoon.
You know, and so the message
here is how can we help
everyone understand that they
are serving the same flag?
Our perceptual
interpretations, our memories
and our thoughts are all
constructs of the mind,
and they differ across people,
even when considering the same
object, event, or evidence,
Yale will expose you to views
different from your own.
And when it does, you can
start by finding common ground
with people when you
don't agree with them.
As Yalies, as our newest
members of Bulldog Nation,
you are all under one flag.
And with the sophomores,
juniors and seniors,
the alumni, faculty and
staff, and with each other,
you have common ground,
an immediate shared bond
that goes deep to the
intellectual curiosity
and the commitment to community
that have brought you all here.
You have just arrived at a
place that values difference
and actively seeks it out.
It is how professors and
students find and test knowledge.
And it is how the university
equips its students,
that's you, to become leaders
and citizens of the world.
But here are the value
of seeking difference
is even more than that, here
it is taken as an article
of faith, it is the coin of the realm,
it is one of the bedrock
principles that governs us
in and out of the classroom.
Let me assume that you have come here
not only to find knowledge,
but also to learn how to
live lives of consequence.
If that is true, you have
come to the right place.
As you take your first steps,
then you will need to become
comfortable with difference,
not just to accept it or
tolerate it, but to insist on it,
you will find guides everywhere
in the classes you will take
the activities you join, and most of all,
from the people joining you right now,
your peers and classmates.
All of them are part of
the liberal arts education
that awaits you.
Your life at Yale has
started and as it does,
here's what I hope you will do.
Keep an open mind, defer judgment,
cultivate your patience, and show grace.
If you are a duck person,
go find those rabbit people
and find common ground with them.
If you are studying all duck courses,
go find the rabbit courses and
see what they can teach you.
And when you find yourself
rallying around a duck flag,
take a good hard look at that
rabbit flag across the field
and the people rallying around it,
and remember that you are all Yalies.
Members of the Class of
2025, transfer students,
Eli Whitney students, visiting
international students,
you belong to Yale and Yale
belongs to you, welcome.
(audience applauding)
(choir singing)
- Good morning, everyone.
To all Eli Whitney
students, transfer students,
visiting international students,
and first year Yale college
students, welcome to Yale.
(audience applauding)
Let me begin by saying it is good,
really good to see you here today.
And many families and loved ones
are watching today's ceremonies online.
And on behalf of my
colleagues here on stage
and the entire Yale community,
I want to extend a warm
greeting to everyone joining us
wherever you are right now.
This is a big moment for
you, our newest students,
and for Yale, I'm so glad you're here.
51 years ago, university
President Kingman Brewster
delivered an address to the entering class
of new undergraduates,
welcoming them to Yale,
just as I'm doing now.
At the time the university was coming out
of a very unusual year.
We can relate.
Just a few months earlier in
May 1970 tens of thousands
of people from across the
country had come to New Haven
and to Yale to protest
the trials of Bobby Seale
and Ericka Huggins, leaders
of the Black Panther Party
who were being tried for murder.
Thousands of National Guard
troops had been deployed
to the city, as some expected
the protests to turn violent.
The situation was extremely tense.
Fortunately, reason prevailed,
the protests remained largely peaceful
and no one was seriously
injured, let alone killed.
Still, these events rocked Yale's campus.
War was raging in Southeast Asia.
Movements for civil
rights and women's rights
were heading in new directions.
And across society it seemed
like a younger generation
was rising up to challenge the old guard.
Against this backdrop,
many people were wondering
about Yale's future.
They were uncertain about
the university's role,
its purpose in a rapidly changing
and unpredictable society.
Standing here today I'm feeling
many of the same emotions
that President Brewster
must have felt in 1970.
Looking out over that
gathering of new students,
he knew many of them are anxious.
He knew they had questions
about what they would do at Yale
and many more about the kind
of society they would encounter
when they graduated.
Yet, in his speech he
was asking them to study,
to go to the library, to write papers,
to conduct experiments.
He was asking them to be students.
And so he gave voice to a
question that was probably
on the minds of many, a question
I also pose to you today.
He asked, and these are his words,
"Where then is the purpose,
"which makes patient learning supportable
"when the world is on fire?
"Where then is the purpose,
"which makes patient learning supportable
"when the world is on fire?"
Today, again, it seems
like the world is on fire,
literally and metaphorically.
The United States is in the midst
of its greatest crisis since 9/11.
We are fighting a global pandemic,
which will be for many of
us, the most significant
geopolitical and perhaps
personal event of our lives.
But that is not all.
This summer, we have
witnessed terrible wildfires,
drought, and flooding in
many corners of the globe.
Some of you have experienced
these climate disasters firsthand.
Not only climate change, but also racism,
extremism, the widening gulf
between the rich and poor.
These are complex challenges
that call out for urgent
and concerted action.
The world is on fire, and again, we asked,
what is our purpose here?
And how do we learn patiently,
seriously and rigorously,
as I sincerely hope you will,
in times such as these?
In thinking about the
answer to this question,
I was reminded of Musar sometimes
called Mussar in English,
a 19th century Jewish movement
that came out of Lithuania,
very close to where my
ancestors were rabbis.
The central idea of the Musar movement
and of similar religious
and ethical practices
beyond Judaism is that
we must improve ourselves
before looking outward at
society seeking to change it.
We must examine our values,
expand our knowledge,
and develop our empathy and imagination.
One of the rabbis of the time
is said to have told this story,
"I set out to try to change
the world, but I failed.
"So I decided to scale back my efforts
"and only try to influence the
Jewish community of Poland.
"But I failed there too.
"So I targeted the community
in my hometown of Rodan,
"but achieved no greater success.
"Then I gave all my efforts
to changing my own family,
"and failed at that as well.
"Finally, I decided to change myself
"and that's how I had such
an impact on the world."
Much like this Sage, we
are here to make an impact
on our communities and on the
world, don't get me wrong.
But first we must start
by improving ourselves.
Your college years are a time to develop
your strengths and talents,
to challenge yourself in ways
you did not think possible,
to gain knowledge and
understanding, and to explore.
Here at Yale, you will encounter new ideas
and engage with people
from different backgrounds
and walks of life.
You will take intellectual
risks and ask questions
about everything from the
structure of the cosmos,
to the structure of a novel.
Improving yourself means
leaving your comfort zone,
signing up for classes
that sound interesting, but unfamiliar.
Going to office hours with
slightly intimidating professors,
you may be surprised by the
conversation that unfolds.
Attending talks by speakers
whose views are different than yours,
and really listening to their arguments.
Regardless of what you
study or the clubs you join,
I promise you that you will not leave Yale
the same person you are today.
You will be changed, transformed by Yale.
We know that you are ready
for these challenges,
and we are excited to see what
contributions you will make
to Yale, how you will write new chapters
in our shared history in the
coming days, weeks, and years.
Thinking back to that spring of 1970,
I'm reminded of four Yale college
students, who with others,
played a pivotal role
in the mayday events.
Kurt Schmoke, Ralph Dawson,
Bill Farley, Glenn de Chabert.
They were serious students
and active in founding
and leading the Black
Student Alliance at Yale.
Two would be named Rhodes Scholars.
That spring, along with Kingman Brewster,
his special assistant, Sam Chauncey
and other administrators,
these students showed
exemplary leadership
during a time of crisis.
There were instrumental in
helping keep the peace on campus
and most likely saving lives.
The world was on fire,
but their time at Yale prepared them
to tackle important challenges,
then and after graduation.
One as a big city mayor
and university president,
others as distinguished attorneys,
all as engaged community members.
Like generations of alumni,
these Yalies were deeply committed
to making themselves better,
making the university better
and making the world better.
You too are joining the Yale
community at a historic moment.
We're surrounded on all sides
by fires, small and large.
And yet I could think of no
better moment to be at Yale.
We begin this academic year
with a renewed commitment
to nurture this community
and the people in it.
Yalies, you will soon
discover love to learn,
they seek out new experiences
and they immerse themselves
fully in everything they do.
At Yale, you can study with
top public health experts
who are advising governments
on the pandemic response.
You can take a seminar
with a Pulitzer Prize
winning historian of Frederick Douglas,
or a leading authority on John Milton.
You can conduct research
alongside faculty members
in over 1200 laboratories.
Yale's great strength now as
always is that we learn from
and are inspired by one another.
Although we come from different places,
we share a common purpose and
that is to improve ourselves
so that we can improve the world.
Yale's mission statement
expresses our highest ambitions.
It says in part,
Yale is committed to
improving the world today
and for future generations.
It goes on to say, Yale educates
aspiring leaders worldwide
who serve all sectors of society.
You, you are those aspiring leaders.
And this mission is our
answer to the question
my predecessor asked over 50 years ago.
I believe the patient learning
President Brewster spoke of
means deep engagement in your studies.
It means challenging your
thoughts and beliefs.
It means expanding the
frontiers of knowledge,
your own, and then the worlds.
It means using your
time at Yale to prepare
for the trials ahead.
In this sense patient learning
is not only supportable,
but essential if we are
to fulfill Yale's mission,
and indeed improve the world.
I will end with lyrics
written by one of my favorite
folk singers, Woody Guthrie
in his song Worlds on Fire.
His words are only too applicable.
While the skies, they're
clearing we'll rise up dreaming.
Build our city from the ashes.
Yes, the world is on fire,
but right in front of me,
I see many reasons for optimism.
Together, as part of this
community, you will dream.
You will build.
And you will prepare for lives
of leadership and service.
Welcome to Yale.
(audience applauding)
(choir singing)
- Please stand.
My beloved Yale family,
as we ready ourselves to
step out onto new ground
in this daunting yet
inspiring liminal space
of the unknown next, we begin
a poignant turn of goodbyes
and hellos that invite laughter,
tears, challenge, choice,
discovery, and pride.
Let us go forth with deep
trust in certain knowledge
that in this place each and
every one of us is welcome,
that in this place, we
will both stumble and soar,
that in this place love surrounds us,
beauty can surprise us.
In this place, light and truth awaits us.
On this day and every day
forward may all that is holy
shine upon us and tenderly
bless our every breath.
May we go in Shalom, in Salaam, in Shanti,
may we go in peace,
Let us begin.
(upbeat classical music)